all right everybody coughed up some
green for the DLC
wait aren't you gonna buy the DLC now I
don't believe in it whoa whoa whoa whoa
let me get this straight
you don't ever buy the DLC I don't buy
it just cuz its new all right I mean
I'll buy it if it's something really
interesting but then I'll watch a let's
play first or get it on a sale but
buying everything new automatically
that's for the birds as far as I'm
concerned they should have just put it
in the game for free and giving things
for free they don't pay the bills you
don't care if indie devs count on you
buying the DLC to survive you know what
this is
it's the world's smallest violin playing
just for the indie devs you don't have
any idea what you're talking about these
people bust their ass this is a hard job
so is working in retail selling the
actual games but you don't give those
people five bucks do you he's convinced
me I'm removing this nonsense from my
steam cut hey leave it in your cart wait
a minute who didn't buy the DLC
Valentino Valentino why the hell not you
don't believe it
shut up what do you mean you don't
believe in it come on you cuff up a buck
you cheap bastard you bought the game on
75% off I worked overtime for this all
right since they only paid 250 for the
vanilla game I'll buy the DLC but
normally I would never do this never
mind what you normally would do this is
goat simulator just buy the new damn
deals see like everybody else thank you
Oh